you're climbing a mountain you try and
get to the top of the mountain
why do you even want to peak then you
get upset they know when we get the peak
here's what happens when people get to
the peak they jump off you're always
trying to get better but is there this
thing where you know once you become
amazing of something
you're amazing becomes you're okay now
and you never stop yeah and I was just
thinking about this like I've had
amazing classes yeah and I was standing
in line at Subway and I was I was
thinking about I was like I
it never stops the pursuit of being
great because every week I have a
different stories I have to get better
at that story there's that but it's like
I have I'm I feel like it never I feel
like there's no it never I thought I
never stops what am I saying I feel like
the tools that are measuring the
greatness I don't have and so sometimes
I feel lost like I'll come into class I
mean like I need to have a great class
and I know some of the signifiers energy
more humor more people laughing more
people or sorry state more people being
engaged right like these things but
sometimes I get I get I get overwhelmed
by not overwhelmed but it sometimes it
loses its me the meaning sometimes the
meaning is lost when I go to class and
I'm like oh I need to have the perfect
class like the concept of meet like
whenever I label it that I need to have
the perfect class it's becoming more and
more meaningless as a concept I don't
[ __ ] as a perfect class because there's
no such thing as the kingdom I'm so
sorry you have to bleep this but there
is no because this is this is the point
of my frustration right now that's why
I'm cursing and I don't curse normally
but it's like there is no such thing as
a perfect class nobody knows what the
servicing I can't even find a person who
has a perfect class or even close to a
perfect class and it pisses me off that
I don't have the measurement tools to be
like oh this is pretty close to perfect
class right like whatever it never stops
it never stops hitting your goal is the
worst thing of all time Jesus Christ I
know that too
you don't want a perfect class then you
have what would you do oh like life is
over you know where to grow hitting your
goal is the worst thing of all time it's
the pursuit of the goal that's exciting
I'm getting lost I feel like there's a
fog I feel like sometimes did Beck I
don't see the lighthouse where the
lighthouse is that perfect class because
there is no perfect class and I see just
fog
and and what I'm losing is my spirit my
Seng my spirit and my drive because I
feel like I'm just stuck in a fog
sometimes and I don't know how to get
out of that that's where my frustration
is coming from and I don't I don't know
what to do
I'm frustrated I'm scared also
I'm scared because I feel myself losing
hope I'm getting emotional right now
because I don't want to lose hope god
damn and I said I wouldn't cry god damn
it but I am I feel like I'm losing her
oh my god I mean this is the this is
what I've been I'm holding in myself for
a little while now I don't want to lose
hope what are you losing hoping find the
imperfect class well you'll never find
it so now what why you say that
why even say something that I won't
possibly ever have and I hope for it
when I know I can never have it because
the pursuit is more important than the
outcome I don't that on a rational level
but that's feeling it how do you make
people feel belong how do i how do i you
know when you look at someone who's
religious and believes in God part of a
leaf of God is the idea of faith it's
not explained it's unexplainable but
it's just it's faith it's faith that
this thing is watching over you and it's
ever-present yeah I don't believe in God
in that sense but that's an amazing
quality to have to have faith well I'm
losing my faith in finding that perfect
class where you're saying and I get on a
rational level it's the it's the it's
it's having it's it's it's it's loving
the process but the process needs to be
tied to some and go where the end goal
is never reachable and I and I'm having
trouble even measuring me getting closer
to something that can't be ever gotten
closer to and it's this weird cycle and
I'm just I'm like I'm sometimes I'm
feeling I feel sometimes defeated I feel
sometimes defeated that's where I'm
losing the hope well your what you're
describing is every creative person of
all time it's never all perfectly lined
up you're gonna go through people you
have the greatest painter of all time
looks at this blank canvas doesn't know
what the paint great writers get
writer's block
that's part of the process of creating
here's what you know people need belong
you know to your foundation that people
need to feel like they belong right
people need belong you know people the
need to belong
people need to belong you're usually
pretty good at helping people right you
may be the best but usually pretty good
at it
and you can always do something to help
people feel like they belong in any
moment you can make somebody feel like
they belong if you wanted to the flip
side of what you're talking about
because you're looking for new things
and more creative to make it better but
the flip side is you get bored if you do
the same thing over and over and like
your speeches that we're working yeah
you cut because you were bored of them
you weren't feeling them anymore this is
not wrong this is part of the process
the frustration will lead to something
great we're diamonds taking shape under
under way under this way we're diamond
shape I'm looking at a diamond ladies
and gentlemen taking shape he's not
there yet it's a bunch of coal right now
right isn't that what is like what
diamonds come from coal no it's part of
the process you're gonna get frustrated
it's the tiredness that's getting to me
it's being it's almost like being in a
relationship with a person
and
and you're tired of trying to make them
better you're tired of working so hard
work not that it's not that it's not
that no but it is tiredness
it's tiredness because you're not
getting the results and you don't know
how to measure the results that's okay
and if I'm just frustrated yeah I'm like
when is it when is it supposed to feel
feel right you're gonna punch what is
the truth the answer is never and always
close I want to just shut up right now
but that's what it is
well that's pretty hard for someone who
wants to belong
yeah but you have tons of people who
want to support you and love you and
help you you you have a phone full of
people who would come and give you love
and support if you asked
you're tired of one doing it by yourself
yeah so share it don't be alone you're
not alone you think you're the only one
who has these problems
everybody watching everybody in my in
believe nation goes through this I go
through this how do I make my videos
better how do I make this series better
and you've only been doing this for her
a couple of years I've had my youtube
channel for 10 years and still how do I
make it better why am I not getting
better how do i improve you don't need
to be alone
sharing the process helps especially for
belong sharing the process with
everybody who who's under you who's
learning from you helps with your with
your audience like keeping it to
yourself is anti belong this anti what
you stand for
you're saying here's this thing that I'm
scared of and I feel like I'm all alone
with and I'm not willing to share it you
don't need to go through anything alone
ever
if vulnerability is strengthened you
never need to go through anything in
life alone whatever you're dealing with
you deal with your diet you're dealing
with your schedule consistency you you
can't get it up but you'll need to go
through anything alone you know what is
this this is the this is the whole like
my children are Annie and Fernando and I
feel like you know you know it's the
parents it's the parents who have kids
and the parents are having trouble with
their money and they're stressed about
the bills they don't want a goal and
tell the kids but they're stressed about
the bills I think you know I think
you're setting them up to lose you know
why because then the kids think that
they need to be perfect mom and dad
never struggled with money why do I suck
you saying there's more of a benefit to
reinforce that it's okay to feel this
yeah that this is normal
did this happen is versus the potential
the potential of them seeing that though
that they will never get it
of course they're gonna get it what are
you talking about they're like Alex I
can't do this how can I ever be great oh
I see what you saying there that's my
fear but yeah but that's different you
how you feel like you can get through it
is different than you feel like you
can't share what you're going through
but that's why I'm sharing I'm not
sharing I know
but you need to split them you having
hope and faith that you can be greater
is a different story than you've been
unwilling to share the weaknesses and
vulnerabilities I think parents who
don't tell their kids that they're
struggling do their kids at the service
they're trying to protect them where
they're just making them more insecure
now you're going to go to your kids and
complain about everything but it's a
real-life situation here's an example
my my my father's parents passed when I
was in my early teens my grandfather
died of Alzheimer's my grandmother had a
series of strokes
my parents handled it very stoic Lee
very stoic Lee I don't know how I'm
gonna handle if my parents well if when
right well my parents passed on I don't
know how I'm gonna handle it and if I
try to handle it like they handled it
and judge myself against how they
handled it as the right way to do it I
lose right like maybe I maybe maybe I
cry my face off and I'm a total wreck
for a week I don't know and maybe they
day too but they maybe they hit it what
you're saying is share shared the pain
to normalize it so whenever they
experienced it they can work through it
and be open and share it and that's a
bigger game yeah I don't think I even do
a good enough job I think I think you
compare yourself to me too much and you
feel inadequate in some things
and that's that's it's not that I don't
feel things I I I'm not afraid to share
things with you I just don't process
them or block a lot of them out but it
doesn't mean that that's the way to be
right and I've created inadequacies
right it's my fault but I don't think
that's the way to be I don't think I'm
not afraid to tell you something you
can't be afraid to share and especially
for someone like you who belonging is
the thing you have to share it
what are you telling people to do you
want them to feel accepted and okay with
their moles and bumps and bruises and
inadequacies and you have to share yours
as an example sharing it brings you
closer to Christie and Karolina instead
of Alex is perfect never makes mistakes
and I suck because I can't figure stuff
out so in the pursuit of the perfect
class sometimes that can be inspiring
sometimes that can be like men yeah like
I want to get the perfect class like
it's never gonna happen and I'm pumped
to chase this big audacious goal okay
but sometimes it is and if you're not
then you focus on all my class yesterday
was pretty good like you jumped to
extremes it's like I'm either I either
had the perfect class or I suck I'm a
terrible human being you don't suck
the reason the perfect class it's a
strive for the perfect class you're
climbing a mountain right
you're trying to get to the top of the
mountain but there is no peak that's the
best part like you don't want there to
be a peak why do you even want a peak
then you get upset then a little peak no
when you get the peak here's what
happens when people get to the peak they
jump off Ted Turner's dad Ted Turner mr
Turner
CNN okay CNN Atlanta Braves like
billionaire multi times his dad wanted
to hit a certain friend be a millionaire
or whatever he did and then he killed
himself and Ted Turner was 20 or 21 or
something had to take over the company
it was outdoor advertising she said I
just had a goal so big that I'm never
gonna hit it within my lifetime I'll
never reach it so then it's going back
to looking at the wins that you've had
you've grown over the past couple of
years you've grown from last month last
semester the year before you've grown
you've gotten better how do you know I
could say Alex Alex you know what you
haven't gotten better over the last two
years you'll excuse my class few years
ago I sucked now great you have to be
your biggest fan and your biggest critic
at the same time no no you don't know
you you biggest critic and the biggest
fan the problem is you just your biggest
critic you're not your biggest fan
[Music]
I'm hard as anything on my
youtube-channel I need to get better my
team needs to get better we need to make
more content everything to get better
and then when people say you're too hard
on yourself I'll say oh dude my channel
is amazing I should win a Nobel Peace
Prize for my channel like I'm a service
to humanity both know so but you need to
be your biggest fan you've grown a lot
over the past two years you're studying
to solve the problem of feeling that I'm
drowning focus yeah and that you want to
keep swimming
there's no end to swimming you want to
keep swimming the swimming is awesome if
you're not swimming you're dying love
swimming I want to swim forever if I
swim to that Island and then I retire
and I die I want the ocean to go on
forever
yeah that's the thing yeah you focus on
the end point there's no end point your
folk you're overwhelmed at the end point
is forever I know what it is but I know
that's just a perspective shift and
loving the growth that you've had so far
and recognizing and celebrating it this
is another one if I'm be nice it's like
don't take it from me because I suck at
celebrating stuff I need so little of
what you need in this area that I'm that
I'm the worst person to model I just
instinctively love everything that I do
and so I lean only in on the on the on
the beat me up I don't want you to tell
me how great I am
tell me how much I suck tell me how to
get better you need more celebration so
celebrate more
[Music]
why don't you deserve it from what great
listen
awesome you're always far away this is
what you break break that mindset break
that limiting belief that's what you
break you think Tony Robbins is done you
think he's perfect
you did every lesson Tony Robbins did
you see the video
his documentary after every session he's
still dissecting with his team -
whatever in the morning breaking down
how the event went how do we get better
Tony Robbins the best of the best
whatever whatever criteria he's one two
three five he's not he's not a thousand
still after an event after doing this
for decades decades still breaks down
with his team after every event how do
we do better how do we get better
because that's the best part you're so
focused on swimming aware yourself to go
there you have a look back at how far
you've gone look back - holy crap the
the other land is so far away you can
always get better but recognize that
what you've done is also amazing look at
all the students who you've helped like
people have gotten married because of
you does the experience you gave them
they've they went off and they got
married what's the answer stay in the
island and never swim if you're never
overwhelmed you're not pushing hard
enough you can always stand up it means
you're not swimming there's nothing
wrong with this point everybody goes
through it and you'll have more of these
and the people on your team will get
them as well and so seeing that you go
through it and how you handle it will
allow you to walk others through it too
[Music]
yeah the most important word ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
that would become like a little beacon
if you want to see the advice I gave
Alex and why he should not have 10-year
goals
check out the video right next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
the people who are stubborn about the
how lose so you're super stubborn on the
why and flexible on the how